the Russian president himself lied into
the face of European leaders saying he
was not planning to attack
it was days before the invasion
Russia is Shameless
they sit at the chair they occupied in
1991 on dubious legal grounds
armed with Evita right and the feeling
of total impunity
Russians are confident that they can get
away with anything and they are entitled
to do anything they want
they think they see it allows them to
violate borders in a 19th century style
imperialist Conquest
they think it allows them to Shell
nuclear power plants and seize them
they think it allows them to unleash
missile Terror on civilians and critical
infrastructure
they think
it allows them to threaten the world
with the use of nuclear weapons
they must be held accountable for all of
this
the issue of responsibility is Central
to the debate we need to ensure that
behavior like this is punishable
otherwise every force in the world every
evil force in the world will be tempted
to follow in Russia's footsteps
I don't need to remind anyone at this
table how many forces on the planet
would like to question
the borders of their neighbors
if Russia can do this why can't they
today we're talking not only about
Ukraine and Russia
the Global Security crisis we all face
is so much larger
all members of the council must realize
that on February 24th Russia attacked
not only Ukraine
dealt a deadly blow to the very
foundations of the United Nations
Charter
no Nation can feel safe until Russia is
held to account for violating the common
principles agreed by all after the
second World War
Russia does not care for them
but they ran 192 other U.N member states
nations of Asia the Pacific Africa the
Middle East
Latin America and Europe are all
interested in upholding the U.N Charter
today
in Ukraine
is fighting to defend principles of this
Charter especially the principle of
territorial integrity
Madam president Russia's war of
aggression has plunged the world into a
multifaceted crisis
the consequences of this crime are felt
far beyond Ukraine
once Russian warships blocked Ukrainian
seaports it became clear that Ukrainian
agricultural exports are vital to Global
Food security
Russia has demonstrated that it is ready
to put millions of people across Asia
Africa and the Middle East at the risk
of hunger simply to achieve its
imperialistic goals
I take this opportunity to thank U.N
Secretary General Antonio guterres and
turkey for facilitating the Black Sea
grain initiative that allowed Ukraine to
resume Maritime grain experts this
summer
Putin recently lied when he said that
most of the grain has been sent to
European countries in fact two-thirds of
the grain were shipped when to consumers
in Africa the Middle East and Asia
the resumption of Ukrainian exports has
tamed food prices and allowed to ease
the acute food insecurity especially for
those most vulnerable
today the Black Sea grain initiative is
under threat
Russian officials are questioning the
effectiveness of the corridor and might
prepare to block the extension of the
initiative once they agreed 120 days are
over in November
we must not allow Russia to resume its
Hunger Games with the world
I therefore urge All Nations especially
those depending on Ukrainian food
experts to put maximum public and
diplomatic pressure in Moscow demanding
to keep the Black Sea grain Corridor
functioning in November and Beyond we
need to protect the vital grain
initiative together
Ukraine reminds a global food security
guarantor despite our own dire situation
we decided to provide humanitarian Aid
to Ethiopia and Somalia
sending them an additional amount of our
grains
Ukraine is interested in increasing
Maritime expert volumes both under the
U.N food program and on market
conditions
while hitting peaceful Ukrainian cities
with missiles Russia uses food and
energy as Weapons against the rest of
the world Putin sends tanks into Ukraine
to kill ukrainians while stealing the
well-being and stability from every
European household with energy blackmail
and playing Hunger Games with Asian
African Middle Eastern families by
threatening the functioning of the grain
corridor we are in the same boat
all of us Europeans
Asians Africans Arab Nations Latin
American states we are in the same boat
and we must confront these threats
together
there is no place for neutrality
I said back in February here at the
United Nations that no Nation will be
able to sit out this crisis created by
Russia it still stands
the best reaction to this crisis
stand with Ukraine to protect the U.N
Charter
Russia likes to talk about the developed
world and the developing World they try
to drive a wedge between ones and the
others
we in Ukraine do not differentiate
all people deserve a normal life
safety and stability and confidence
but we must stay United to stop Russia's
blackmail
and the war on Humanity it launched
your colleagues the most important
pillar of International Peace and
security is the territorial Integrity of
states
no country is allowed to change
internationally recognized borders by
force
Russia has badly damaged this principle
and now the threat of war is hanging
over everyone's head
to restore International Peace and
security we need urgent and decisive
action
yesterday president zielinski proposed a
peace formula which includes not only
accountability but a mechanism of
security guarantees based on article 51
of the U.N Charter
Ukraine has developed the key of
security compact proposing a modern
multi-layered mechanism of guarantees to
ensure Ukraine's security until the
moment it becomes part of NATO
this document though is much broader
than a tool of guarantee to guarantee
the security of Ukraine only
we see it as a universal mechanism that
can be considered and applied to other
countries and contacts in order to
strengthen Regional and Global Security
architecture
Ukraine keeps working with Partners to
realize the vision of the cave security
compact
this is our added value to International
Peace and security for all UN member
states thank you